What kind of heritage?
Well, you know, I would love to talk
about the Trinity for sure. That's
something that is interesting for me.
Uh, but I do have another point that I
would like to or a few that I would love
to to bring up with you because, you
know, I've been watching you for some
time.
I like your logic, you know, and uh I
would like to to to pick your brain with
a few questions.
So, you don't So, you're not a
trinitarian.
Well, um, you know, like I I believe
that there's definitely like the father
and the son, right?
Because you can't you can't like
separate them, you know, the father was
not literally like he was still in
heaven, right?
But uh I like me myself when I hear like
uh you know you know in the New
Testament I think it's Luke that says
like uh God is one here. Oh Israel, God
is one. You know, before saying like you
shall love the Lord your God with all
your heart, soul, and mind.
And then uh so you know like the the
concept of the trinity what is
interesting to me is that it's it's like
uh it's uh it's like interpretation,
right? But when we look at the Bible
itself, it seems to really push toward
like to say it explicitly that like God
is one. Uh so how how how would you
convince me on on the trinity for that?
Well, the trinity is that God is one,
right?
Yeah. So I I do believe that God is one,
Yeah. He's one one divine nature, one
essence.
Yeah.
Right. Just there's he exists as three
distinct persons. So when you're saying
that God is one, you got to be clear on
what category you're talking about. Are
you talking about one being or are you
talking about one person? And I think
the scriptur is clear that there's one
being that is God, one divine being. Um,
and that there's three persons that are
identified as God who share that same
divine nature, that same divine essence.
Well, the the Holy Spirit, if you look
in the Old Testament, right? Uh, so it
it could go on multiple people at the
same time. And you would probably agree
with me that new belie like uh that that
Christian believers
uh that uh like they there can be
multiple people with the Holy Spirit in
them, right? That's correct. So the same
spirit.
Yeah. Right. So So doesn't that make
more than three at the end?
No. Because that's the still that's
still the same Holy Spirit.
Right. And this is what I'm I'm arguing
is that this is the same spirit. Like
the same way that the Holy Spirit can be
in multiple people at once, the same way
that God is one being in multiple
shapes at once. So, are you saying do do
you believe that the son is the father?
Well, you know, like Jesus,
his Hebrew name was Yeshua, right? Uh he
uh he
Yes or no, bro.
He said that. Yeah. He said to
Philillip, right? If you have seen me,
you have seen the father. So, I I don't
know. Like he seems to say pretty
explicitly. What What's your take on
that?
Well, that if you've seen me, you've
seen the father. Um he right before that
he says that he's the way to the father
right so he's not saying that he is the
father just that he is the exact
representation of it
well when he says I and the father are
one does isn't he saying that uh
they're one in essence
sorry
they're one in essence not the same
person
but he didn't say
he said he says the okay he says the
same thing about the disciples he says
in John 17 that you know let them be one
in us and I in them I and I you are you
in me I in you um and they in us. So
would that mean that the disciples are
also father and Jesus? So, so, so I
sometimes I'm gonna admit Avery when I
watch your uh because I've been watching
you, right? Obviously, and when I watch
your reasoning on the trinity, sometimes
it feels like when the Muslims are
trying to say uh like, oh, we don't we
look we don't believe in the trinity.
Obviously, they do believe in in weird
kind of trinities also, right? Uh or or
some kind of aspect like that. But it's
just the reasoning after a while it just
it becomes dumb to me. Okay. So, and
what I mean by that is that uh like if
you look in Romans uh 8:11 where it says
the spirit of God who raised Jesus from
the dead lives in you. Uh and uh you
there's another place where it says that
the spirit of Jesus lives in you. Like
obviously like we're talking of like it
just it it kind of feels dumb to me to
to to push that like uh obviously like
God manifest himself in multiple ways,
right? Like sometimes you see the glory
of of God when Moses, let's say, is
hiding in the cliff of the rock, right?
And would the glory of God be a another
another person, a distinct person or you
know what I mean? Or or is it just
another way to like another sight of
God? You know what I mean? Like the Holy
Spirit how I see.
So let's so let's let's let's break this
down because there's a lot of places
that you're going. So let's stick with
the first thing that we brought up or
that you brought up where Jesus says
that you know I and the father are one
and you're taking that to mean that he
and the father are the same person. So
my question is he says the same thing
about the disciples that the disciples
are one and that the disciples are one
in him and the father. So does that mean
that they are all one person? The
disciples, Jesus and the father, are
they all one person?
Well,
uh, no. No, they're distinct persons.
Yeah, that that I do agree.
So then when we see where Jesus says, I
and the father are one. It doesn't
necessitate that those are they are the
same person. They are distinct,
right? They're distinct persons. But
what are they one? What in what sense
are they one? They're one in essence,
not personhood.
But when he says, "Him who has seen me
have seen the father."
Yes. Again, he is the representation of
the father,
right? And that's that's and I feel like
we're saying the same thing in different
ways.
No, but we're not though because you're
saying that he is the father, right?
You're you're saying he is the father.
The father is the son. That's what
you're saying. I'm saying no.
No. This is this is where I'm I'm saying
that it sounds like like like basic like
uh like bad logic to me. You know what I
mean? Like when when I I hear like
you're saying so you're saying Jesus is
the father. No, I'm saying he's God. God
is one as it was always pushed in the in
the Tanakh in the Old Testament, right?
If you look at throughout the Old
Testament
and but when we're looking at this where
we see these persons, we see these
identifiers. We see the father, we see
the son and we also see the holy spirit.
Are these three distinct or are they the
same person?
I would say that you know it's the same
person because ultimately
and that's what I'm okay. So you are
saying that the father is the son.
Actually I would say yes the the father
is the son. Yes. Absolutely. So
absolutely when you're saying when you
talk about bad logic, how is it how is
it good logic to say that the father is
the son and the son is his father? How
that makes sense?
Well, listen, hear me out. Okay, so if
if
uh you know the father would make
himself a son of God, aka a son of man,
right? Because
how would he how would the father make
himself a son of himself.
Well, that isn't this isn't this what uh
like Muslims they they argue that that
same question, right?
Well, that well this this this question
will work against you against your
theology. Not
no it doesn't because I haven't
explained yet. So I can't I can so how
how the father makes himself a child of
his own self is because I would argue
that the father as he created all
things, right? Like he made the
universe, right? So he's pretty pretty
amazing at at creating, right? So
so if if he uh if he created the
universe and he can do basically
whatever he want, right? Uh he made
himself human and that aspect of
humanity is the son of God, right? So
because he cannot say I am like when
when Jesus came first century,
you're saying he became the son. He
wasn't always the son. He became the
son.
Yeah. Yeah. That's that's what I'm
saying. I'm saying that God is I I think
God is one like you know like I don't
believe that when when we're going to
die that uh that that we're going to
have uh three thrones and you know what
I mean like and a bird on one and and
two men like looking at us like you know
what I mean?
So when so when it says that the ancient
of days has his throne and the son of
man has his own throne what do you do
with that?
Well because I believe that the son of
man is going to reign on it for a
thousand years. Right.
But but this is in this is in the
presence of the ancient of days. A
thousand year reign is on earth.
Where where could you pull out that
scripture? I'm not familiar with it.
In in Daniel Daniel 7.
Yeah.
Daniel 7. It talks about how there are
thrones and then the ancient of days
takes his seat and then the the son of
man is then brought to
And could you uh let's pull it out.
Okay. I just want to read it because I I
really like because you know I've been
uh and this is I'm staying on the same
topic. I'm not jumping. Okay. But uh the
uh you know like in other if you look in
other translations not not the ones that
were uh taken from the Latin Vulgate.
But if you look at translations uh from
uh multiple Bibles that that do exist
that uh you can find which I have a few
uh it it does say you know in the the
place where it says baptize them in the
name of the father the son and the holy
spirit right in John
you know what I'm talking about
obviously uh well it says in in this
translation it says uh baptize them in
my name and when we look in the in the
book of acts every time that they
baptize it's always only in the name of
Jesus. It's never in the same name of
the trinity in the name of the trinity.
And these translations they they they
I would have to see that where it says
where it doesn't have the the in the
name of the father. So
I I can pull I can give you it's it's
called the reconstruction scriptures. Uh
so
scriptures.
Yeah. Reconstruction uh Bible. If I
bought it off Amazon and there's a few
other Bible that uses these uh
references. So it's a it's a Bible
that's uh that's
it's not it's not based on the Greek
then because the every Greek manuscript
says in um you know name of the father
son and holy spirit so
I believe that they have found uh
because I
there's not a single manuscript that
doesn't say that bro in Matthew 28:19
uh yes there are and there
we'll get to that in a second because
that's another subject we'll get to that
I I like I like to stay focused. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
I'll deal with that after you're done,
Shay.
So, here it says here, as I looked, the
thrones, so plurality of thrones were
placed.
The ancient of days took his seat.
Right? So, one of the thrones, the
ancient of days took his seat. His
clothing was white as snow, and hair
like, you know, pure wool. His throne
was fiery flames, wheels were burning
fire, stream of fire issued, and came
out from before him. A thousand
thousands served him and 10,000 times
10,000 stood before him. The court sat
in judgment um and the books were
opened. All right? yada yada yada talk
about the beast.
Then verse 13, I saw in the night vision
and behold with the clouds of heaven
there came one like a son of man and he
came to the ancient of days and was
presented before him. So in the presence
of the ancient of days, son of man is
here. And what does the son of man
receive?
dominion, glory, a kingdom. All peoples,
nation, languages, and serving are
serving him. His dominion is everlasting
dominion. Um, it won't pass away. So,
there's thrones that are there
in the heaven.
Yeah. I I'm not denying that.
Okay. So, you have one of them is the
ancient of days and the other one is the
son of man.
Yeah. Can I can I answer that from my
So, you're saying that the father is
sitting in both thrones? That's that's
the father.
No. Well, obviously what I think is
that's the manifestation of Jesus as a
human, you know, how he was raised up to
the right right hand of power, right?
So, this is this is what we have is that
uh you know, uh or you're going to say
that this this is a vision, but I think
that this vision is from the future is
from this is a obviously a vision of the
future. So, I don't think that when you
say that there are two tones, they were
always there. What I'm what I think this
paint the picture of is the everlasting
kingdom. This is the son of man
receiving authority after opening the
the seven seals, right? And coming to
reign for a thousand years.
I'm still just confused. Is Jesus the
father or not?
You're breaking it down.
You're trying to to dumb it down so we
can have a easier conversation. Look,
uh, this this this argument with the
multiple thrones, I think it talks about
the eternal the everlasting kingdom.
Okay.
I understand. Is he is he the father?
I think he's I think he's the father and
I would love you to convince me
otherwise. I think he's the father that
you believe that the Holy Spirit is also
the father.
I believe it's the spirit of the father.
Yes.
Okay. Does the father work on anyone
else's authority?
Does the father work in anyone else's
authority? No.
Does he hear from anyone else?
Does he Does the father hear from anyone
else? Well, I think I think he does at
some point. But what do you mean by
that? Maybe I'm It's just my
Is there somebody that tells the father
what to say?
I don't think so.
I would agree with you.
I would hope not.
Yeah. That'd be crazy. So, this is where
we this is where we agree. The father
doesn't work on anyone else's authority.
Yeah.
And he doesn't hear from anyone else in
the sense that there's not anyone
telling him what to do or what to say.
He's not the one receiving commands.
He's the one who
I think he would like he would represent
the ultimate chuck calling, right?
All right. Yes. So, with that being
said,
if the Holy Spirit is the father,
yes.
Then we have to ask this question, bro.
We'll go to this verse. We're going to
go to John chapter 16 verse 13. Okay.
Let me just make it a little bigger.
Whoops.
All right. It says, "When the Spirit of
truth
comes, right, the Holy Spirit, who is
the father, he will guide you into all
the truth, for he will not speak on his
own authority,
but whatever he hears, he will speak,
and he will declare to you the things
that are to come.
Right? So, the spirit of truth will not
speak on his own authority. The Holy
Spirit doesn't speak on his own
authority,
but he only speaks what he hears, what
he's being told what to say.
So, if the Holy Spirit is the father,
Yeah.
who is the father hearing from and on
whose authority is the father uh
speaking of?
Now I like that. You know what I mean?
It's it's very good. Yeah. No,
got logic.
Yeah. No, it's good. It's good. So the
thing is this is that you know like the
same you're saying the same essence and
but because it's it's obvious that they
like when they came like the when Jesus
came on earth like he was not working in
the full authority of the father. Right?
So that that's that's obvious. You can
see it.
He was working in the authority of the
father.
Well because because he was not he was
not raised to the right hand of power.
Right. So, so because of that, he didn't
have like 100% God.
He didn't have that he didn't have the
authority like uh like that he that he
received at his resurrection.
So, this is the question. You have you
have Jesus who says that he's not
working on his own authority. He's
working on the one who sent him.
But you believe Jesus is the father. You
have the Holy Spirit who doesn't speak
on his own authority but speaks on
someone else's authority and hears from
someone else but you believe the Holy
Spirit is the father. So the question is
whose authority is the father speaking
and working on
because it literally says not his own.
Whose authority is the father
speaking on?
All right. And who is he hearing from?
Uh that you're But that's the Holy
Spirit right there, right?
Yes. Yes. We we'll we'll do the Jesus
one next. Whose authority when it says
the Holy Spirit? Because you believe the
father is the Holy Spirit.
So if the father is the spirit,
hold on because this this logic right
here is is like it's good to to say that
they have different functions, right?
It's it's very
not just different functions, but that
they are different persons. when when
Jesus because because you could point me
in many different other passages where
it says like Jesus where he says only
the father knows you know not not the
angels in heaven and then you would say
like is Jesus the father right so that
that's good and you're say you're doing
the same thing with the holy spirit
I wouldn't I wouldn't go to that verse
and and try to show that the Jesus is
different from the father in that way
even though I can
I I don't I I there are other more
powerful ones this right here
it's it's the powerful one. You know
what I'm saying? This shows look
obviously as we agree
the father does not work on anyone
else's authority. He works on his own.
Right.
Yeah.
Here it says the Holy Spirit does not
work on his own authority. He works on
someone else's. That shows that he
cannot be the father.
Well, if if I can if I can. Okay. and
and stop me if I'm I'm being stupid.
Okay.
So, so the thing is this is is from that
angle I I feel like the Holy Spirit is
sent out, you know. It's
that's true.
And and and it's like it's like me like
you know like Jesus is the word of God.
So you can't separate yourself with from
your word in a way like you know so he
is part of it is the Holy Spirit is is
it's like the invis invisible hand of of
the father like you know. So, so the the
Holy Spirit, the
Holy Spirit is the presence of God, the
power of God, but he is not just a
force. He is a person. He's personable.
He has intellect. He speaks, he
commands, right? He we see this through
the scriptures. So we see that the Holy
Spirit although he does have a different
function than the word of God and the
father himself. He has a he has his own
function and role but he's also a person
who has a mind who has a will who gives
commands. He appoints the apostles and
stuff but we see and we see that he is
distinct from the father even though
he's not separate. There's not a
separation. They're one in essence but
they're distinct in personhood. That's
what we believe. And if you don't say
that,
then you're you run into absurdity, man.
No, I I I agree that the Bible clearly
shows separation when it comes to the
Holy Spirit.
Distinction
distinction or not separate, excuse me,
but uh so it it clearly shows
distinction when it comes to uh the
father, the son, and the holy spirit.
They don't have the same function and
all that. Uh it's just that as I said
earlier it like you know when the Bible
explicitly says like hey like God is one
you know
but you're saying he's he's one but he's
three at the same time right?
Yeah. So when when I'm when when the
Bible says God is one one what?
One God.
There you go. One God.
Yeah.
Not one person. One God. One God. One
divine being. One divine essence. Mhm.
And this one God, this one divine
essence exists as three distinct persons
or inseparable,
co-eternal, co-substantial.
They fellowship with one another. That's
what we have to conclude when we read
the Bible. It forces us to conclude
that. If not, then we we have we have a
we have a problem.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I agree. And to be
honest, uh logic, that was not my go-to.
like that's not really like I'm not I
was never sold on that on that point.
Okay. But it was something that I I I
would love to talk about more because
the people that I surround myself with
definitely don't believe in the trinity.
Right. So this is this is something that
uh that me I never I never really you
know set in stone because it's it's a
it's a topic that is
it's hard to understand.
Okay.
Yeah. It's complex. It's complex for
sure. I would say, you know, don't
delete your friends, but get get around
get around some biblically sound
brothers and sisters, bro, trinitarian
believers, and hear what they have to
say. Like, you know, you're hearing what
I have to say. We're talking through it.
Hear like talk with them about it and
see like this type of stuff. Look, if
we're going to go with oneness theology,
oneness modalism theology, right? this
idea that God has just not three persons
but these three manifestations right
these three ways that he manifests
himself.
If we go with that theology then we have
to say that the father is hearing from
someone else that the father is working
on someone else's authority. That's what
we're forced to say if we hold to
oneness theology
and we both know that that's not
biblical.
Yeah. based on on that that verse. I
kind of like it. I I think it's pretty
powerful like you said. So, uh that's
that's pretty good.
Good.
Hey, with with all uh that that logic
under that hat, man. Like uh can I pick
your B as something else or is it
something else? What what else is there?
This is the most important thing,
man. This is the most this is the the
thickest book in the world, man. Like uh
with the content you gota there there's
more to talk about, man. If you don't
have the right if you don't have the
right concept of God first and we we we
can't we can't move forward, man.
No. Well, I told you I was never sold on
that point. I just wanted your logic and
I I like I like what you you said, so I
want to hear more.
Hold on one second. Chris, you got to
come on YouTube for him to hear you.
My bad.
What' you say? What was that last part
you said?
Talking to you, uh, Fish.
Ah. Oh, okay. Uh, yeah. And uh what do
you think of Matthew 5:18-19?
What what does that got to do with what
we talking about?
This is not about the trinity. I think
you you you made your point. This is
about other uh theologic uh points.
All right. If I made my point, then what
do you believe about God? Now then
about God, I think like I think it makes
sense. Okay. The the concept of the
trinity makes sense. It's just very hard
to explain. Very hard to explain. Uh I
would
trinitarian now,
huh?
You trinitarian now?
Uh I would say I would love to to Jesus
to explain to me exactly how it works
when I see him. Uh like uh but yeah, the
Bible does seem to point in in a
trinity. Yes. And and you know what me
I'm constantly molding like I'm
constantly learning. I'm not someone
that is going to be like uh unable to to
change. I just I just want to learn and
you know so I'm only uh two years and a
half into the faith, right? So
yes and and you know what with you with
you saying that hearing what you said
then yes we can definitely talk about
other things. Um I just wanted to make
sure like where where you were and
um yeah you're you're you're in the
right direction. Praise God. So
praise God.
And clear and clearly you seem you're
you're humble about it and you're open
to the scripture like you're I love
talking to people who submit when
scripture is scripture and says it then
then you go with where scripture leads.
Right. So all right Matthew 5. Yeah.
Well, if you know Paul when the at the
time that he was writing these letters,
were these letters were was the the New
Testament recognized yet or was it not
yet recognized?
Uh there there were there were gospel
accounts that were circulating. You're
talking about when Paul so like Paul he
quotes Luke's gospel for example.
So so they they were in circulation. I I
wouldn't say that there was a
compilation of the New Testament just
yet obviously, but but his letters were
not scripture yet.
No, they were scripture. When he wrote
them, they were scripture. Yeah.
So, they were scripture, but were they
recognized as scriptures by himself? Was
he saying that what he's write what he's
um saying and giving is is from God. one
and and two you have Peter who says that
Paul's letters are are scripture
and hard to understand.
Yeah.
Right. That's what he says that that
wicked people twisted their own
destruction in second Peter. Uh so when
when uh he says Paul says that all
scriptures are useful for doctrine for
correction and for reproof
uh in righteousness. Uh, are we talking
about
even like Shabbat,
like the laws, you know, like like the
Torah?
All of it.
All of it. And do you follow the Torah?
Do you follow the the Old Testament
laws?
No.
Why not?
I'm not under them.
You You are not under them for
salvation.
I'm not I am not under the Mosaic law.
So would you agree that Paul followed
the law? I already heard you say that. I
know you you know that in Acts 15, Paul
was in 21 he was uh he was saying that
he was following the law, right? Like uh
James, right? He made that point to that
that he would like take people who had
shaved their heads. They made a Nazarene
vow.
What what is your what is your real
question?
Well, I man I could go on but uh you
know Matthew 5:18-19
or we can read 17 also.
Yeah. Yeah, I believe that he fulfilled
the law and he says he fulfilled it.
So when you say fulfill is it the is it
is fulfill a synonym of destroy complete
to complete to finish
right? So when he says complete the law
is complete a synonym of do away with
when he says
huh
it means to finish so it's done.
So finish is a synonym. So we're talking
of synonyms here. So he's saying I did
not come to do away with the law.
I came to to finish it.
Yeah. So he came he finished the law. He
brought it to its full purpose. It's not
destroyed because by the by our faith we
still uphold the law. Right. And it's
the law that shows us why we need
Christ. We don't destroy the law.
Amen. So So when he says in 18 and 19, I
did not come to destroy but to fulfill.
For assuredly I say to you, till heaven
and earth pass away, not one jot, not
one tit will disappear from the law by
no mean until heaven and earth pass
away. Whoever there
until fulfilled until all has been
fulfilled.
Uh then whoever breaks one of the least
of these commandments and teaches men to
do so shall be called least in the
kingdom of heaven. But whoever does and
teaches them, he shall be called great
in the kingdom of heaven.
So, what's your objection?
Uh, well, I think it's pretty obvious
here. I'm I'm asking why don't we keep
the law if
Do you keep the law?
I I try.
Okay, cool. You can keep the law. That
you can do that. Um, the law has been
fulfilled. That's what Jesus said. He
says, "This is what I told you in the
law of Moses, the Psalms, and the
prophets."
Yes.
Right. And he and he said he fulfilled
it.
All of the law. Do do you agree that
Jesus fulfilled it or did he fail?
I think he definitely fulfills it and
but the word fulfilled that the way that
we say it it's a synonym of of abolish.
Right? So he's saying because uh because
when he says whoever there breaks one of
the least of these commandments talking
of the law
he's saying that like we we are not to
break the the commandments the law. And
when we're saying the commandments he's
he's talking about the law and the
prophets, right?
So um when you're talking about you keep
the laws and you try to keep the laws
are and you believe that you are uh
commanded to keep all the laws of Moses.
Well it's like the Israelites when they
were in exile at Babylon, right? They
wouldn't keep the temple laws or the
Levitical laws because they couldn't,
right? There there was no temple. There
was no priest.
Hey fish. Um
yes,
le let's say um when the Mosaic law came
around, if Abraham lived during the time
of Moses, would Abraham be able to say,
"Ah, no. I don't want to go by the
Mosaic law. I want to stick to the
covenant that you made with me. I don't
want to go by the Mosaic law." Would
Abraham have that option?
Well, I don't think that one covenant
enols the other.
So he would have to accept the Mosaic
covenant then though, right?
Yeah.
So let let's say if Moses lived at the
time of Jesus, you you believe that
Jesus brought the new covenant. Of
course, right?
I do very much so.
So if Moses lived during the time of
Jesus, would Moses be able to say to
God, I want to stay with the Mosaic law
and not the new covenant? Okay, that's a
very good point you're making. But what
how comes then that Paul goes in the
temple to make
sacrifice fish would Moses be able to
say, "I don't want to adhere to the new
covenant. I want to stick with my own
covenant." Would he be able to say that?
The the thing is, of course not. And
you're trying to pinpoint me into an
answer, but it's not what we're arguing
here. And maybe I I'm not making myself
clear enough. I think it
I think that the new covenant and the
old covenant and the old covenants in
the plural, they all go together.
They're the same thing. They all go
together. And uh and and we we are still
because if sin is a transgression of the
law, 1 John 3:4,
then then this sin continues existing,
right? But fish, what I I believe what
logic is trying to tell you and show you
here is that Jesus is the fulfillment,
the completion
of the law, of course, right? And under
Jesus, we have that new covenant of
course, right?
And and what is what is the what is the
law of the new covenant? We are under
what it says.
So uh so so when when he says then
whoever breaks the least of these
commandments is he talking about what
what what commandments is he talking
about?
Well what what the the context that he's
talking about obviously is the law of
Moses and the prophets. Right.
Right.
He says that he came to fulfill them. If
he didn't fulfill them then we would
still be under them.
But for
he fulfilled them. So we're not under
them. We're not under the law of Moses
anymore. We're under the law of Christ
which is literally what the Bible says.
But what is the law of Christ then?
The law of Christ is faith and it's
love.
Faith and love according How do you
measure love? How do you know what is
love?
Do you go according to what God has
revealed in the scriptures or do you go
according to what you decide love is?
Yeah, we're talking about the
scriptures.
So when he when he says
here's an example like here here's an
example. Um or I guess a uh a contention
here. You brought up Acts 15.
Yes.
What were the Gentiles commanded to do?
Okay, le let's read it. Okay. Acts 15.
Okay.
Were they commanded to keep the Mosaic
law?
Yes, you can read it. Okay. So So yeah,
like can I read it?
Yeah. Yeah. Show me where it says that
they're supposed
So it's Acts it's Acts 15:19-21.
Okay.
So it is my judgment therefore that we
should not make it difficult for the
Gentiles who are turning to God.
Instead, we should write to them telling
them to abstain from polluted idols,
from sexual immorality, from meat
strangled and from blood. So, right
there you have Mosaic laws. Okay. But
then if you read 21, let me let me
finish 21.
All right. Go ahead.
For the law of Moses has been preached
in every city from the earliest time and
is read in the synagogues on every
Sabbaths. So, not only are the Gentiles
expected to go on the synagogues in the
synagogues on Sabbath, but they are
expected to learn the law at their own
rate. And if you go in Acts one,
that's not what it says. That's not what
it says. Hold on here because I I don't
want you to jump too far. That's not
what that says. But it so it says here
that they are to um abstain from things
polluted to to idols from sexual
immorality and things that have been
strangled
things from and blood.
This is straight from the law.
What about what what about um well yeah
of course like you know the ten
commandments are from the law of Moses.
We we we acknowledge those. Mhm.
Um, where where's the where where is the
uh isn't isn't it in the law of Moses to
be circumcised?
Yes.
Were they commanded to be circumcised?
Well, every Sabbath they would learn
about it when they would go.
No, no, no, brother. Were they commanded
to be circumcised?
Absolutely. They were commanded to be
circumcised to keep the law. Like Paul
says in his letters, he says, "For
circumcision has value if you keep the
law, but if you do not keep the law,
your circumcision has become
uncircumcision to you." So, before you
make a connection, I just want to go to
Acts 15:1.
Wait, because you just said this in the
same passage, Paul says, for the ones
who are not circumcised, don't do it.
For the ones who are who are, you're
you're circumcised. You're good.
Yeah, that's true. Because
why why does he tell the ones who are
not circumcised not to look for it?
Because look, it if you go in the first
verse of Acts 15, okay, this is the
whole thing here. This is the whole
topic, the whole debate of Jerusalem.
This is why Paul went from Antioch down
to Jerusalem to have that meeting with
the brothers in Jerusalem. It's because
of Acts 1 when it where it says certain
people came down from Judea to Antioch
and where uh and we're teaching the
believers unless you are circumcised
according to the custom taught by Moses,
you cannot be saved. And this is the
question. The question was never are
Christians supposed to keep the law.
Obviously, they are because it's it's
the whole book. It's the whole
scriptures. It's the whole doctrine. But
are they saved by the law? And this is
what Paul felt compelled to go all the
way down to Jerusalem to address. And
and
so can you show me where they are
commanded to get circumcised, please?
Because we saw their commands. Stay away
from blood, stay away from things
strangled, stay away from sexual
immorality, and uh stay away from things
offered idols. So
where are they commanded to be
circumcised? And they they did not
command the whole ten commandment also
in that
where do we see them being because the
the the subject is here circumcision and
the commandments that are given it's
here. Okay.
Where are they commanded to be
circumcised?
God logic. I know you have that hat on.
You got that that logic hat on.
I know. So I need I need a logical
answer
and I need I need you to to be logic too
with me. Okay. So So let's be logic
here. Okay. In these four commandments
that he's saying that they need
you're starting to waste my time. You're
losing me.
No, this is these four commandments that
that he is saying the new converts to
do. These four commandments are things
that pagans come from in temple
prostitution. Uh
I'm going to ask I'm going to ask him
one last time. Where do they command
them to get circumcised?
Okay, let's let's see. Okay, maybe I
will rephrase. You are not commanded to
circumcise in the New Testament. Oh,
but Paul s But Paul circumcised Timothy.
But oh, oh, not so Paul circumcised
Timothy. Yes. Did he circumcise Titus?
It's not written. But he did. He
it it is
is it?
It's it he was not forced to circumcise
Titus. Why?
Because you are not saved by the law.
No. No. Because he wasn't a Jew, right?
Held to those customs. He's a gentile.
And so that wasn't like it wasn't um
prescribed upon him to be circumcised.
So you're saying circumcision is only
for the Jews.
I'm that was a custom for the Jews. That
was under the law of Moses. Why weren't
the Gentiles commanded to get
circumcised?
They're commanded to follow the law of
Moses. What's up?
Can you read uh Galatians chapter 2 uh
verse 9 on the screen? My friend, I
think that's going to be a perfect verse
for our friend here.
Galatians need to be read in fullness.
You cannot read pull out one verse of
Galatians. This is how you end up with
the doctrine that the law is done away
with completely. Uh if if you read the
Galatians the entirety of Galatians with
mind that he is speaking of salvation by
the law, you will understand that what
what Paul is saying here because Paul
kept the feast. I must by by all means
keep the feast in Jerusalem. So he kept
the feast. As was his custom, he went in
the synagogues on Shabbat. He
circumcised Timothy. And if you look in
Acts 21, you can see that Paul
There's a reason. There's a reason for
it, Fish. And we're about to read it.
Okay. Paul goes in the temple to make
sacrifice. Did you know that?
But even Titus who was with me was not
forced to be circumcised. Interesting.
Though he was a Greek.
Yeah. And and I think that's to make a
point that you are not saved by works.
But if you know you not you are not
saved by keeping the law. And this is
the whole debate in Acts 20.
Why wasn't why wasn't it incumbent on
him to be circumcised though?
Because it is not required for
salvation. And also here here it says
when James and Caiaphas and John who
seem to be pillars perceived the grace
that was given to me, they gave the
right hand of fellowship to Barnabas and
me that we should go to the Gentiles and
they to the circumcised.
H why would it separate the two in that
instance? You think
do you know that the circumcised is a is
literally a synonym with the Jews?
Which because
when you say the circumcised, it means
the Jews
because they're Jews and that was their
custom.
So that's why they put it in there. But
it separates the Gentiles from the
circumcised.
Correct.
Yeah. So, so when if we go back to 15 on
that,
I think I think this is great. You know,
if you read if you pull out verses out
of Galatians, you will be able to make
it seem that way 100%. And and any and
any other verses that are isolated can
can definitely support doctrines like
that. Okay. But if you look in Acts 21,
you can see that Paul goes in the temple
to make uh sacrifice.
You keep jumping and you're not
answering what is being brought. Bro,
I I think I answered I think I I said
that uh you are not required to keep the
law for salvation. And this is what in
Acts 15 to keep the law at all.
I think we are. Yes.
Okay. Why wasn't Titus sac uh
circumcised?
Why wasn't he circumcised? You are
required, but you will learn every
Shabbat as he is being read in the
synagogue. Circumcised, bro.
Because that's not how you come in
covenant. That's what they did in Acts
15. If you read it, this is this is why
the debate was there.
Titus is breaking the law over there,
huh?
Yeah. And so are we all. We're all
breaking the law, man. No one can keep
it for salvation. And this is why
did you just say Titus is breaking the
law?
Can I finish a sentence though because
I'm trying to I'm trying to to speak and
you're just trying to trap me. I'm just
trying to make a point. Okay. Here, as
we can see, he literally says,
"Brothers, okay, listen. Okay, we cannot
put a heavy burden, okay, that we were
not even able to our fathers were not
even able to keep on the new converts,
okay? Aka keeping the law perfectly for
salvation, right? this is this is the
point of the debate for Jerusalem and
he's saying guys okay this is we're not
going to bother them with circumcision
and all these things because that's not
how you come in covenant and then if you
go on to read they say because we
believe that we are saved by grace in
the same manner as they okay so he's
he's recognizing that we are saved by
grace now what I'm trying to
disassociate is that what everyone as as
soon as we speak of Christians keeping
the law everyone says ah we're not saved
by the law and We agree. No one is saved
by the law, but the law has never been
done away with.
Okay. Um well, thanks for that. Looks
like we're not going to really get
anywhere. Um you know, we brought up,
you know, I heard your point. Um we
don't know why Titus was was not
commanded to be circumcised.
We see that the Gentiles were not
commanded to be circumcised even though
they were given specific commands. Um,
and so, you know, if we're just using
scripture and logic here, we clearly see
that the Gentiles are not under the law
of Moses.
Why did Timothy getized then?
We're under the law of We're under the
law of of Christ as it says. Let me let
me ask you this. You you said that um
you said that sin is is transgression of
the law.
I didn't say is in 1 John 3:4.
Does does the does the Bible say
anything else is is sin?
Uh yeah, it has a a lot to say about
that. Yes.
So how else is sin defined?
Everyone who breaks the law is in fact
committing lawlessness. For lawlessness
is the breaking of the law. 1 John 3:4.
Yeah. What else? How else is sin
described?
Well, you tell me what what's your
definition of sin? Because this is my
the Bible. Okay. So like, so for
example, if you go to Romans chapter 14
at the bottom,
Mhm.
says this,
but whoever has doubts in whoever has
doubts is condemned if he eats because
the eating is not from faith. For
whatever does not proceed from faith is
sin.
But what is faith? Define faith.
Does that have to do with the law?
Yeah, I would say so. Do you know what
what what is faith?
Can you show me where this has to do
with the law here?
Yeah. So, if you read in in James, okay,
it says it it gives the definition of of
faith. It says, "He who believes but
does not have faith cannot please God."
Okay. The demons believe and they
tremble.
The law.
Well, it's because faith is putting your
beliefs in action.
What does that do with the law? Well,
it's because this is this is our guide
on what to act, how to act, how to
behave. If if Paul said if Paul said
you're conflating, sorry, I'm sorry.
You're conflating works with works of
the law.
Where does this have to do with with the
law, please? The law of Moses. Where
does this have to do with this?
Well, if you read James in that
particular place, he talks about how uh
Abraham kept his statute, judgment, and
commandments. Therefore, he was seen as
righteous.
Abraham kept what?
His huh?
His his uh judgments, precept, and
commandments.
So, the law the law of Moses.
Well, it's the law is of God. It's
eternal, brother.
Wait, did he So Mo so Abraham had the
law of Moses?
How did he Why did he like There was
clearly a law, man. If you look Noah,
did Abraham have the law of Moses?
The law was given to Moses. It was
officialized at Moses. But if you look
there,
the law of Moses, right?
The law of Moses is not of Moses. The
law is of God.
So, did Abraham have the law of Moses?
Yes or no?
No. Moses had the law of Abraham
so much. So,
so you see what I'm saying?
So, so Abraham had the laws where he had
to, you know, wear certain things and
then fringes at the ends of his thing
and tabernacles and, you know, uh,
well, he did sacrifice. He had he had
those he had these laws that were he had
a temple.
Yeah. He was not not the the like the
temple laws were were given at the
temple but there was clearly sacrifice
huh
through Abraham or Moses
through Moses. This is this is strictly
this the tabernacle laws strictly come
from Moses. Moses had the there was the
law of Moses and then you have way
before Moses you have commandments that
Abraham is given to keep that those are
two different things. Would you agree?
Yes. And just the same way that Noah
made the distinction between clean
animals and unclean animals, right? in
the she got seven animals, clean
animals. And
so conflating conflating Abraham's
commandments that he kept from God and
being obedient to God and the law of
Moses, that's an error. They're not the
same thing. So when this talks about I
and I acknowledge
transgressing the law is sin. I
acknowledge that. But also
whatever does not proceed from faith is
sin. That's not having anything to do
with the law. It's to do with your
faith. That conviction that you have in
the Lord. If it doesn't come from faith,
that is sin. Romans 14:23.
So, when we have here, we have the
scripture says that we are under the law
of faith. You're familiar with that,
right?
Uh this is what you're you're uh quoting
right now, right?
Yes.
The law of faith. Yeah.
Yeah. Like the literally it says it that
we're under the law of faith. That's
literally what the scripture says.
But are you under the law or not?
I'm under the law of faith.
Okay. So you're under the law.
I'm under the law of faith. The law of
You're under the law.
Because when it says we're not under the
law, but we're under grace. You're
saying I'm not under the law of Moses.
I'm not under the law.
I want you to be Yeah. I want you to be
clear when you I don't want you to
conflate the two because it sounds like
you're thinking there's only just one
law. There's only one context of one law
that that's not as we're seeing there's
different commandments given right in
different dispensations, different
covenants. I am under the law of faith,
not the law of Moses. That's what the
Bible says.
So why would Jesus like correct
something just to do away with? Like you
know when he says literally he says the
Pharisees and the scribes are sitting in
the seat of Moses. Therefore do
everything that they say but do not do
what they do. For they say and do not do
because they're still under that
dispensation. Because they're still
under that dispensation.
Right? He did not fulfill the law yet.
That's why it hasn't been fulfilled at
that point. Luke 24:44,
he says, "This is what I told you while
I was still with you, that everything
that's written about me in the law and
the prophets and the psalms must be
fulfilled, completed, finished, filled
out to their purpose."
Tell me that they wasn't.
Avery, you're you're saying you're
saying, "Look, the Mosaic that that's
done away with." But then they quote in
Acts 15 from not drinking blood. I'm
sorry, but if I invite the Holy Spirit
in my heart, it will not tell me right
away, Fred, do not eat blood. Right?
Like that that's not obvious to me. I
have to go look in the law of Moses to
know that, right?
Do you are you familiar and this will be
the last thing. Are you familiar with uh
with where where Paul is doing his
evangelism and he's doing his ministry
and um he talks about how he approaches
different groups?
Yes. All right. So, how do you
understand when it says um it says here
to the Jews I became as the Jew in order
to win Jews. To those under the law, I
became as one under the law, though not
being myself under the law. Is Paul
under the law?
He's not.
So, when I say I am not under the law,
Paul here says that he's not under the
law. Mhm.
But just saying that we're wrong for
thinking that.
Mhm. So, do you know do you know that
there was the law that is what Jesus is
correcting the Pharisees that come to
him when they say, "Hey, how come your
your your disciples are not washing
their hands before eating?" And he's
saying, "Hey,
where where anywhere is that called the
law?"
Man, there was more than one law.
There's a there's many laws.
Can you show me in scripture where
that's called the law?
It's the traditions of the ancients,
right? Can you show me fish where that
is referred?
I will. I will. I will. Okay. Here.
Okay. Here. Okay. In the book of Acts.
Okay. You have it heard say that
it is not lawful for a Jew to eat with
Gentiles. Okay.
Okay. So here. Okay. It's in Acts 10.
Okay.
Where do they refer to it as the law?
Please
be graceful. Be graceful to me. Okay.
Gracious to me here. Okay. Just a moment
here. Okay.
Yeah. I just, you know, if you say
you've been watching me a lot, you know
that I like to get what I asked for now.
And I'm trying to give it to you right
now, brother. Okay. So, here uh Okay.
So, it's when Peter, he goes in the
house of Cornelius.
We know we know the situation.
Where do they say
it says here? You have heard it say that
it is not lawful for a Jew to eat with a
Gentile. Okay. But I I am telling you
that God has shown me that I am not to
call any man defiled or unclean. But
this
where they where do they call it a law?
Where do they say that that's the law?
Well, he said you have heard it say that
it is not lawful.
So let me finish what is being said as
the law.
Let me finish this point. Okay. You have
heard it. He says lawful therefore a
law. Okay. You have heard it say that it
is not lawful for a Jew to eat with a
Gentile. Go look where where that law
is.
You're missing. Hold on. So
that law is not in the Old Testament.
This is a
be the last thing Fish because it seems
like you're purposely doing this. I
don't know if it is or what. Seems like
you're purposely doing this. I
understand that they that under the
Pharisees, they had their customs and
their traditions that they deemed uh as
as you know commandments, right? to this
day
where does the scripture refer to their
practices as the law
they do not because it is not law
their traditions is never identified as
the law
but this is why he's saying to the Jews
I have become like the Jews because he's
referring to the Jews who keep these
these men
as a Jew I come to a Jew and to one who
is under the law I come to them as one
who's under the law even though I myself
am not under the law. He's not talking
about the traditions of Pharisees. He's
talking about the only thing in
scripture that's ever identified as the
law,
which is the law of Moses.
If you look in in in Romans, he says the
law of sin and death, the law of this,
the law. There's seven laws just in
Romans.
Hey, a fish, we we can't take it
seriously because you just went to not
sitting with uh Gentiles and whatnot.
But we actually see in Galatians chapter
2 verse 11 down it says here but when
Caiaphas came to Antioch I opposed him
to his face because he stood condemned
be for before certain men came from
James he was eating with the Gentiles
but missing the point I'm not defending
that law fish but when they came I'm not
defending that law
but when they came he drew back and
separated himself fearing the
circumcision party. Yeah.
This is where Paul rebuked him for that.
Yeah. And I'm not defending that law.
You're missing the point. This is
man-made laws. And I'm talking about the
law of God. And And
I'm going to finish.
Why would they ever refer to man-made
laws as the law
because that there were many laws, man.
There was the laws of the land, the laws
of the Roman, the laws of the Pharisees.
And
thanks for coming, man. Thanks for
coming. Thanks. I appreciate you.
Appreciate you. Thanks for coming.
Thanks for coming. That's
what What was his point for even
bringing it up then? His point was is
that see something else is called
lawful. See there were there were things
that people considered the a law like
the f the tradition of the Pharisees
they considered it to be commandments
and laws. So when Paul says that he's
not under the law he's saying that he's
not under Pharisee traditions and and
man-made commandments.
Wow.
Absolute liar on the scripture.
Brutal. Brittle.